hey everyone how's it going so I am off
to Matt's new apartment I'm pretty sure
a zero furniture bullet he does have is
the HTC vive which is one of my favorite
so far favorites virtual reality
headsets and I don't have one yet so
we're all going to mats to play and I've
packed a few things for the dog I've
packed some alcohol I've got cupcakes
but again we don't have furniture but
that's okay are you ready to go see
Jenna Matty ready to go for ride I think
I might bring a blanket because Matt
actually has nothing not even to bring
us a blanket okay baby going for a
wonderful drive here not necessarily in
rush hour but at shore feels like rush
hour no matter what time it is in Los
Angeles there's always traffic now he's
in the backseat
the windows are currently up jokes
really adults here start walking his way
towards the entrance as he opens the
front door the rooster and hen ask hey
man were you crowing how good is that
I came over then all on myself will
with guys look we just locked Maddy
right now how much fun he's having in
this empty apartment oh my oh yeah I see
lights out there Good Samaritan we've
gone so far it's really good Jenna's
been helping a lot she's a lifesaver
good girl Janna Levin is just carrying
coal for buses you know that we're
pathetic I'm not raising a dog Jenna's
riding a bike and we are the two little
kids in the carriage
so we're gonna have a wild night tonight
we're gonna go to dinner and Ed got me
this really cool is it would you say
with a bonds up what does it say it's a
bonsai tree what's the guy's name Chris
McVeigh power big bonsai he's it hard to
take care of but I barely even big
rabbit says the beginnings kicked back a
few brewskies with a poo and then
randomly then the crow gets up doesn't
say a word my walks towards the front
door
and the rooster in the hen yell across
the bar hey where are you crowing hey
where are you crowing you get it cuz
he's a go he's walking away and they
don't know why are you going I am dead
inside yeah you guys don't like to joke
this is like the 15th time I've heard
the job I bet if I told my man for that
joke you would it's fun it's fun it's
funny it's cute it's killed my grandpa
that joke it would kill waiting for a
reason to exit this video and that's the
Anessa
the scene how is the lighting so good on
this
like when you're over stereo yeah
hey guys got a show to press all right
so we're hanging out here this is Kyle
how we even rolling I'm Jeff
yeah we're live right now Kyle Jesse's
gonna steal this is our proprietary
stuff hey we're I'm centering myself do
you know we're hanging out so Kyle's
birthday sorry we served you dairy not
telling the joke again I'm just gonna
cut to the end of it okay so there's a
rooster we're going I did predict the
door delivery I said that was a joke
could you brush my hair when you're done
oh look how nice this is good last night
I lost good we look good we all
but thank you play Friday honestly
there's not many things I'll dress up
for hey so I am off to get my car
because we had some champagne last night
and even if I drink a very little tiny
bit I do not ever want to drive so I
love my garden I also have to go pick it
up so that means I'm going to have to
take Maddie in an uber do you want to go
on an uber ride Maddie Cory here where
do you find us
you scared me I was like oh my god these
are these chocolate chips he sure did
loving them okay this is like the new
hangout spot before no park no furniture
this is great when I came in out for
item 7 as well thanks my god I can't
believe we did that
so let's go they get a treat you're
right I did not if I'm owning moment I
did it
mm-hmm I was born to cram it because it
has had limited carriers my rooster I
had
the rooster in the head both go at the
same time they exclaim hey where you
crewing
you get it because he's a crow where you
throw it I just dropped off Maddie I
don't even what I did all day we just
like walked around and now we're their
treat and that is shopping for a
photoshoot like the end see you how are
you finding everything okay yeah good
okay cool
I've been sitting in the car for 20
minutes because you guys would write a
viewing oops
yep I forgot my phone where are you it's
your shot man you stunt zip DOL's pigs
if that pant I like that jacket a lot I
like that better than the green one hey
hi
if you're wondering about my hair I'm
actually not sure either I found a few
bobby pins that I didn't have a hair tie
so it was kind of like a desperation
attempt of trying to get the hair out of
my face we're getting smoothies and
Jenna absolutely can't even look at me
because of the hair
I don't like it just Everage are looking
surprisingly yes
so what you're saying jenna is you're
surprised yeah every time I look at
youse Oh queasy I know today I went to
the Best Friends Animal Society shelter
and it was so awesome like be helpful so
it wasn't awesome because it's very sad
because all these puppies need homes but
the stuff that they do there for the
dogs like they have dog training so
they're making dogs more adoptable you
have to go down you have to know what is
with you however go best buy cakes or a
bunch of places I need to find a hair
tie
last Betty's it's an ordeal a mattress
store is on Yelp do not recommend I'm
not sure I don't mind if I don't have it
I only found on Yelp how's it going
how's your smoothie that's good and deep
in thought deep in flop says Jenna when
you replay the footage you'll see how
deep in thought I was didn't even know
you turn the camera on because there's
no beep I turned it off Oh sneaky very
very stealthy we're going to the cake
store now and get some items I'm doing a
collab with one of my YouTube friends
tomorrow
very excited that's why I need your help
oh you're free after Madonna's she'd be
real quick oh I won't wear my hair like
this you can't wear your hair anywhere
like this it's driving me bonkers
hi my hair is progressively getting
worse as the day goes on I need it also
needs a tripod mount guys I have a
question for you Jetta what is the
average room temperature when you set
your thermostat what would you set it to
71 72 71 depends is it hot or cold
outside
Wow 71 more average I hear something
like 68 cuz you're wasteful
we got the items anything we did of us I
usually Park it in the same place
but the last time I went I didn't Park
in the same spot and I thought I did and
I felt some stole my car so I was about
to call like I don't like who do I call
to called I'm a one-dog buster okay
we're going now room and board don't get
hit
are we really doing on the board there's
a lot of restaurants close to it
I just put a backup boss point out I
need another bobby pin
I have a hair type hang on shut are you
serious but ready we're voting for the
release you don't have one
wait I got another room not are you
ready for this I never been in here I've
been gonna have this spaghetti spaghetti
I think I'll have the spaghetti I think
I'll have the spaghetti I also will have
this beginning the what
Maddie I got you a present I got him a
new modern food bowl look babe he's like
but what is it perfect height for his
little Bob hey hungry yeah I just got my
hair done
can you guys tell the difference